hi thanks ever for joining us you gave a
wonderful distinguished lecture last
month exploring the fertile area of
games between learning agents and you're
back again this month for a deeper dive
with algorithms and machine learning
groups here I'm very curious to hear how
your trip has been going and what's
bringing you back Microsoft Research is
a great place with lots of great people
somehow the way the Distinguished
Lecture was set up it didn't turn out to
be the best time to extend it for a
longer visit them now back mostly the
work with Nikhil but I've been talking
to other Microsoft researcher this is a
great group there are a lot of great
people here could you go into some
high-level details about the talk you
spoke the distinguished lecture where
you spoke about a new no regret model to
study behavior in massive online games
like for add options and traffic routing
and things like that could you describe
some of that work so one interesting
aspect in if you think about game theory
from a sea s perspective that a lot of
the games that we care about
like I guess Microsoft surely must care
about adoptions but I guess another
prime example is packet writing on the
Internet those are really repeated games
that you're not happening once but they
start happening over and over every
millisecond millions of them at you know
a day and what's really important about
them is not any single act but instead
the overall performance like for any
single packet on a packet writing if the
system can deliver a packet on time they
just drop it and send it again which
works just well the adduction is every
single ad is a couple of you know a
fraction of a cent usually and what's
really valuable is the volume of ads
here
in this kind of setups the classical
notions of game theory maybe are less
applicable and it's very natural to try
to use for the participants to try to
use and explore exploit style learning
algorithm to figure out what might be a
good strategy they often don't exactly
know who the opponents are if you're a
you know packet router you don't like to
know what are the other streams of
packets but you can try sending it
someplace and and sending packets in
some direction and see what happens and
that's a good way to figure out what's
best
similar six applying the expression is
trying and then you know seeing how fast
we get silly burden and okay that was a
good ride that was a bad read similar
thing happens in adduction where there
are other parameters I guess if you're a
you know pizza company you do know who
are the other pizza delivery center but
you don't know what the advertising
exchange and so again trying to explore
what are the good ads for that
successful ads is a good way to learn
now if I want to employ classical
learning theory here one important facet
here is that the prior the environment
in which I'm working is not the patient
prior because the other participants are
also exploring learning it's not a fixed
prior in fact the environment reacts to
me if I start advertising very
aggressively with high bids in something
there the opponent might back off and go
away or might compete higher or I don't
know what he'll do but it's not a steady
patient prior environment but instead
something else maybe not the worst case
but something interesting certainly
where the environment reacts to me and
in that sense this no regret learning
which is what we're using in our work is
great because that works against the
first case adversary in particular it
works whatever this environment
but one question I raised in the talk is
that an opponent who wants to himself
you know in the ads or Roth his own
packet is not actually worst case so
maybe the worst case notion of the no
regrets theory went a little too far and
the interesting example to think about
that even if you're playing a two-person
zero-sum game so every time I win you
lose paper scissor matching pennies
whatever your goal in playing this game
is distinctly I guess to win which
otherwise mean you want me to lose
that's not the same call as you want me
to have high regret you just want to win
you're not not versed
you're not versed kiss from the regret
perspective universe kissing in the
sense of wanting me to lose that's not
the same sake so it would be interesting
to find the sort of mole that
understands this issue is better but
certainly anything that works with no
regret offers certain guarantees because
that's a guess there is an interesting
concept that came up during the talk was
this idea of a course correlated
equilibrium which seemed to be at a high
level it seemed to be that if we could
get humans aware of their behavior we
could get them all to correlate their
actions in a way to achieve a better
equilibrium than what we popularly known
as the Nash equilibrium where everyone
is selfishly looking out for themselves
and I'm very curious to hear your
perspectives on why you feel that's a
good equilibrium to study why the
intersection of game theory and computer
science naturally gives us algorithms
that allow us to reach such equilibria
and how we might implement this in
practice so early working in learning in
game theory which actually started from
the econ community not from the computer
scientist
I guess maybe predating our existence as
I feel or certainly free they think are
interested in game theory was aimed at
hoping that these learning players will
reach a Nash equilibria today we know
that that's not going to work at because
we have computational complexity without
showing that finding that equilibrium is
hard so in particular simple learning
algorithm can't find it because no
algorithm can or at least unless some
complexity classes collapse what happens
when players engaging in Anor ignites
their learning behavior is that they
naturally get correlated and the way
they get correlated is that if we're
playing a game together we was trying to
learn our behavior from past data then
that past data correlates us we're
learning from the same since we have a
shared history and the chat history
causes us to do something that
correlates us so in some games this
correlation goes away in the limit and
at the end we converged Nash equilibrium
but in other games we do not and our
behavior even in a limit will converge
to something that's what's called
correlated equilibrium it's an analog to
Nash equilibrium except for relying our
behavior to get correlated so one
advantage of this this is that it's
computationally feasible like in
particular very simple learning
algorithms can converge to it unlike
Nash equilibrium that is computational
difficulties it also is a natural model
of behavior to try to update based on
data or at least I believe it is and
mint and datasets often show that people
do achieve the no regret property that
the learning requires it's not clear
it's a better model
it's a reachable model and it's a model
that contains all of the Nash equilibria
so Nash equilibria are particular points
in the big set of the
years and course-corrected equilibria
are a convex set surrounding these
points it's a bigger set it's convex
which has advantages in finding it is it
better
it's findable and if you can say
something about or correlate all of
these correlated or correlated
equilibrium that there's something
powerful about all kinds of behavior
including Nash equilibria there is a
subtle issue here if I actually make you
aware that we're playing a particular
course correlated equilibria then you
might not want to play your part it's
not obvious or often it's not best
response for you given that you know
what I do to actually do it you can
somehow think ahead of stuff ahead and
be a bit smarter and maybe I can try to
be a bit smarter too and it's not clear
about this thinking ahead behavior will
do and the reasonable models we stay
still stay in the become backside of of
course correlated equilibria
what's more questionable when I can
predict the behavior can I predict which
part of this set our behavior will be at
I'm not sure you you mentioned the econ
folks got interested in learning and
game theory together before computer
scientists looked at it but I have a
personal opinion which is that you are
one of the first people I look up to who
started thinking computationally like
the the my textbook that opened the
world of game theory to me was
algorithmic game theory with tim
roughgarden you and vazhi Donnie and I
found it a very refreshing change
listen I know you should not forget the
only son is another and I think I didn't
get the first edition though I got a
later date in or one of the editions
it's not listen itself so could you in
give a retrospective on how game theory
evolved and how the computational
subfield that is algorithmic game theory
evolved so I certainly wanna start with
giving christos papadimitriou the true
credit for making this revolution happen
I heard Christos talk about game theory
when I first showed up in the US as a
postdoc researcher I think certainly
late 80s maybe even earlier at the time
so he was interested in game theory much
much before the rest of us or many of us
got interested then he started to take
take up games here again and and when
this change in the way computer
scientists think about it game theory
happened is around the turn of tech
around mm or maybe 1999 or 8 I'm not
really sure when the first talks
happened where he started to champion
the sort that for you know however long
computer science as a field our main
mission was to design algorithms design
machines think about how machines would
work and that with the advent of the
internet this really changed reach
designing individual machines but
they're the most important thing is how
do these machines collaborate with each
other and that we should think of the
internet via a game theoretic thinking
where multiple parties your individual
laptop and my individual laptop or on
rather against another rather
collaborate and compete with each other
in a sum that somewhat shared some but
not so shared goal the way my laptop is
optimized it's not actually trying to
have good experience for the rest
the world it's trying to make good
experience for me to reach the Internet
and that's the same for your laptop and
that's exactly what game theory tries to
model where everyone's selfishly
optimizing for themselves that is what
these machines are doing that's a
profound change in thinking he gave a
whole bunch of talks at different
conferences and really profoundly got
all the certainly DC reticle computer
science community but I think the
broader CS community interested in this
way of thinking the book you mentioned
he wrote the preface for it it's a
beautiful profess which I recommend all
of you everyone read and you must be did
with know I'm Vijay and Tim is wrote
some chapters and asked some other
people to write chapters Christos
included so that we can really really
fast react to this change of thinking if
one person writes a book that will take
a while you have to write all the
chapters if you ask everyone to write
just one chapter each then we can put
something on the shafts of everyone very
very fast and that's what we did but you
got a lot of you to correlate and
collaborate collaborated but my interest
in the industry really stems from
Christos is convincing argument I
actually spent a sabbatical in Berkeley
in 1990 2000 and that's when I started
to work on this
many large part prompted by crystals so
while I like the idea of bringing this
the in bringing computational thinking
to econ or actually being in game theory
to CS I I should give credit where
credit is due
Christo's was the one that really
started this revolution and like looking
ahead where we are in an online social
interaction world now in an increasingly
digital life it feels like all these
arguments that you just described are
even more vital so do you see game
theory playing a vital role going
forward like what's the outlook
definitely you're totally right in many
different ways one problem in applying
game theory to human behavior is that
it's a totally non-trivial trust well
what are incentives in very simplistic
game theoretic models you have a nice
and clean objective function you saying
that the traffic writers goal is to
deliver the packets as fast as possible
that humans interest is to make as much
money as possible and so on when you
have a very clear objective function
then game theory offers a beautiful and
elegant model what will happen in in in
behavior it's less clear if you don't
actually know how to model behavior so
some of the examples to describe were
the humans involved rather than rather
serve or automats we have to have a
better model of what do humans really
want and one interesting sink that's
happening exactly part of the same
digital revolution is that we have a lot
of data traces of what people do so you
know hopefully and this is happening we
can infer better of actually what is a
good model of human behavior of other
people actually want about objective
function describes them not to model
their behavior no regret learning is an
attempt at such a behavior it ignores a
lot of different aspects so certainly
there are some data sets that we're
looking at where no regret learning is
not a good behavior more maybe in large
part because the participants don't pay
enough attention no regret learning
assume that you actually are paying
attention to what's happening and
updating your behavior sufficiently
often so that's one issue sometimes
they're other you know attention span or
interest or how much you care how often
you update your bits is an important
parameter that's not in these models
but there are other ways that that it is
not a perfect behavioral model of what's
happening even in places like adoptions
sinking of advertisers that update very
very frequently so those are advertisers
that clearly pay attention and they seem
to have an algorithmic tool behind them
to allow them updates you know many
times a day better understanding of what
drives these models and what's important
really to better and better use of game
theory but I think game theory will
remain an important tool and there was
one interesting thing that came out
during your talk where you commented
that in these ad auctions for example on
Bing ads or something often there are
these predictive black boxes that will
give the users their entire payoff
curves which allows users to reason
about not just what's the result of the
action they took but also what if they
had placed a different bid and so on and
I realized that having access to such
predictive boxes basically allows game
theory to make some kinds of assumptions
but it can also lead to some frustrating
thing where we don't know what's inside
these black boxes and that seems to tie
neatly with all our efforts in trying to
make these black boxes more transparent
more interpretable and just in general
there is this push with an AI to make
these predictive black boxes fair
accountable transparent and I'm curious
where you see the the potential
synergies as we start building these
models of users how how do you
anticipate the interaction with game
theory in the years to come interesting
questions you're asking in a lot of
different connections here so maybe
there are two parts that I want to
separate a little bit so what was
relevant in in the adoption model is
what do players know so if you're a
writer and you chose a particular
fastest and your packet and then clearly
you're getting no feedback of what would
have happened to your packet had you
send on another pass you gonna have to
start the paddock that way too so the
feedback there is about the pass you
selected and it's not about other pass
in contrast in that auction the
company's being included do give better
feedback they tell the cut Kedar the
customers if they ran a bit for a
particular period of time that what
would they giving you a so called curve
giving you what other bits would have
given you a few had you pay that
different bit than your payments would
have been higher and your your but you
your head would have seen by more people
this response curves are very useful for
learning clearly more information it's
easier to learn and Bing as does Google
or any other company does have enough
information to give this to make these
predictive curves correct
there is no prediction here they simply
know what happened and they can give you
actual results of what would have
happened had you bit higher they know
what everyone else paid they simply know
what the bits were and they can
aggregate these numbers and tell you
what the answer is
now one part one issue they got raised
during the talk is to advertisers
trusted these curves are correct and I
have no information better people trust
it on the Bing website but I do
understand that there are certainly
trust issues at other places especially
their trust issues if you not only want
to give them past data which is a fact
you should know like things should know
but instead want to give a suggestion of
what might be a good bid and so-called
recommendation a recommended action
there there certainly trust issues and
beaders was a thing and many other
places preferred to use third-party
optimizers in fact you to lack of trust
I believe who knows if being maybe
really optimizing for me or are you
optimizing for it for being itself for
the company and so there is the version
whether do I trust that the data you
provided is correct and that might be an
issue so a bigger issue is do I trust
your recommendation and then there is
the third issue that your recommendation
might be based on machine learning which
we don't fully understand and it would
be nice to have a better understand of
um oh maybe that would help the trust
issue but part of the trust issue is is
is an incentive compatibility issue if I
you know if we playing chess and I
suggest that you know you really should
make that move but you're playing
against me you might think that hmm
she's suggesting I move that goods for
me or that's good for her
so in this extent there is a trust issue
that's not about the the lack of
understanding of what causes machine
learning to make a suggestion but
instead just literally in some way we're
we are incentives are aligned but in
other ways they are not so there is
possibly an incentive problem that's the
I'm sure for anyone who is looking up
your work and others work in algorithmic
game theory they will see the phrase
mechanism design come up often is that
could you explain it a high level what
that is and could some ideas from their
help with this incentive alignment
problem and engender trust sure man ISM
design is is the high level it's
designing algorithms that will be good
for selfish users you know the
prototypical classical example is second
price auction so if we auction off a
single item
and we could auction it the way you
contract for selling a house namely you
make an offer and then the highest offer
will get taken and is gonna have to pay
whatever he offered in which case
there's a lot of strategizing going into
what might be the right bid you want to
get the house but you would like to get
it cheap and then there is second price
where again the highest bidder wins but
the pricey pace is the second highest
bid and that is the minimum bid he had
to make in order to win not his actual
bid but the smallest number he could
have had which effectively does the
strategizing for you and it is a little
easy to sing so that in this second
price it's best to just tell the true
max mmm you're willing to pay because
that's not going to be the price
mechanism design is to offer name said
trying to design my own isms where this
simple truthful behavior is everyone's
best behavior in the system no matter
what everyone else does it certainly
makes life easier one issue of is using
manage designing the kind of situations
I talked about in the lecture that is
gifts that are repeated that you have to
be careful it's taste taste tres sorry
Stace
a good man is a good strategy for people
to tell the truth even in the repeated
setting for example and a second price
auction it does not I tell you an
iteration wrong but my true value for
this it is Baba 10 seconds later the
reserve price will go up just a sec
below my true value and look what
suddenly I'm gonna have to tell my value
pay my value that's not gonna be so good
so there's a beautiful theory of single
shot man isms that are their true
stirring is a dominant strategy that is
the good
here for people and we are only now
start to develop the area called dynamic
mechanism design that wants to develop
good mechanisms that stay good even in
the repeated setting or are designed for
being good in a repeated setting popping
up from the technical level I wanted to
ask meta level questions about the
research process right for people who
are interested in game theory and were
getting started reading up on the
literature
the vast fascinating literature and
exciting new results in dynamic
mechanism design can be quite
intimidating to see acronyms thrown
around like stock fox ICI soda
I'm curious could you elaborate a bit on
the bit on the community bit on the
research process what it takes to make
an impactful contribution so I guess
these acronyms you're throwing around
our conference names and in fact
interestingly these RC recon France
names so despite this being an AI
distinguished lecture series I actually
more identified as a member of the Siri
community though in the economics and
computing space there is a lot of
interaction between AI and and Siri so
Fox talk is the two premier Siri
conferences and a lot of theoretical
work or some Amano's theoretical work in
this game Siri economics interface does
get published in Fox stock EC which
stands for ACM conference of economics
and computation is dedicated conference
to this topic and in fact it's a
conference that has a multiple different
tracks as a Siri track has an AI track
and has a empirical track applied track
empirical track and indeed the
conference regular conference attended
there's a lot of sea rotations with a
lot of people from the AG
immunity and even love some people from
the econ community regularly show up and
submit that they work at EC so EC has
been a really great felt at Randolph
mixing and you know at the interface of
AI and Siri even some amount of machine
learning they were actually more
classically iron and the AI people like
REO pro kochia or David Pyrex or or you
know Santo or a whole bunch of them that
are really interested you offshore I can
you know there's a long list of a leader
i researchers who are very interested in
the game Siri interface often these
people don't literally asked the same
questions but they're very related
questions and very it's a it's it's a
really great community where people
interact with each other
you asked how one makes an impact I mean
the very computer science and many of
these science fields work is the
apprenticeship system of getting PhD
students to work with an advisor and I
definitely think that the way as you
point out the the literature is vast and
just someone completely on their own
getting started in reading literature
seem like a very hard task and I
certainly wouldn't recommend this to
people and in in fact having some
guidance with someone senior in the
field I think is the right way to get
started and I guess one way this person
can help you or maybe you can realize
this that some of the changes in life
and some of the changes in perspective
because of our computer science
perspective changes the kind of
questions we ask and working on those
questions is post incredibly impactful
because these are new questions and also
maybe a little bit easier to make an
impact because often you when you
realize that yes there is an amazing
literature that there is a lot of
beautiful work but this is a new
question like for example I was
originally thinking of price offender
here's a question like this there's a
lot of beautiful work in the classical
game Syrian literature on vanity that
Nash equilibrium is guaranteed to have
socially optimal outcome and when is it
when it doesn't have socially optimal
outcome but it they much less asked the
question that when it's not actually
literally optimal how a visit and it
does make a big difference if the valve
farad equilibrium is is vanishing and we
are in a tragedy of the Commons kind of
situation versus yeah we lost a little
bit it's not so bad and making that
distinction is important and it's a
question that has not been extensively
studied historically in in economics
asking these new questions based on our
new perspectives can lead to impactful
research I think so and I think the
combination of learning and games is
also a bit like this even though there
have been history of thinking of
learning and games as a combination
again I think the Eco and focus was what
is the kind of learning behavior that
helps the players find the Nash
equilibrium as a kind of pre play or
chip dog before the game on which we
coordinate on a Nash equilibrium and I
guess our perspective is the big data is
thinking of learning as I as a behavior
model this is what people do not to find
and I hope you Librium this is just real
life and I want to know what happens and
for students who have got started on
research or our early stage career
researchers I'm very curious if you have
any advice on your organizational
principles for research or how do you
balance demands on your time depends of
my time I wish i
better you know there are lots of things
you want to do and I guess you have to
be figure out what works for you for
protecting some of your time I really
like teaching I like interacting with
people who don't yet know the field and
showing them the beauty in algorithms in
game theory but at the same time I also
want to have enough impact in research
as you get older you get us to fair
amount of service and it's an impact to
the community and I guess you care about
that too and of course all of us have
some personal life so this is not even
for 24 hours but you know less than that
because you might want to do other
things in your life it's a hard task and
you have to find your own balance of
what might be right and what's important
I don't know if I have a really good
advisor any good habits for being
productive and asking impactful
questions and research any daily habits
that you have that do you think I mean
one thing that especially since I'm
doing this at Microsoft and maybe some
of the audience are Microsoft or other
industry researchers is I find the
pressure coming from the National
Science Foundation to write grant
proposals very helpful
it makes one sink every you know a
couple of years had to pitch farms
research not an existing result that you
already proved and you want to explain
to a conference but in a way it gets you
involved in to effectively writing the
introduction new paper before you prove
the paper that is before you know what
results you have you need to try to
explain to someone that you will care
about the results this is very important
you you need to be able to convince
yourself that what you're doing will
have an impact and it's important and
it's good idea to try to write this down
and try to convince the community of
this
and engage in the sinking possibly
before you spend you know months and
months figuring out the answer I don't
know what replaces this if you're an
industry researcher but as an academic
and a chef is making me or NSF and other
funding agencies making me write grant
proposals and as annoying as it can be
when the deadline pressure happens at
the high level it's really great that
people engage in this I love our sinking
of what I also like the idea of somewhat
going with the flow and what I new and
interesting questions and keeping your
eyes open of what are the research areas
which are new and exciting and where the
kind of knowledge and tools that you
bring to research could be impactful is
something I would like to I did in my
past I hope I did in my past and I
suggest everyone that should be open to
do somewhat changing areas as we
conclude the chapter I'm also curious to
hear your outlook not on the technical
side of how game theory what are the
interesting questions are there but how
we might see it implemented in society
or in applications like what's the role
of government what's the role of private
actors and how might this play out well
it's a very hard question not so sure I
I know how to react to this so I mean in
some way but government and the rules of
government do is a form of mechanism
design you can interfere with what's
allowed and what's not allowed and what
are the ways we're interacting with each
other as a society in places like
adduction companies and to demand ISM
design oh so they designing their
mechanism but there is a higher level
version where you know Microsoft
competes with Google or Facebook or
whatever all the competitors and that
mechanism design is governed by the
rules of the country or
legal loss and stuff like that so that's
a management design question also so
there are a lot of like high-level
questions of this forum game series off
there is the sort of game theory of the
kind I more talked about in the lecture
whose goal is more trying to understand
what likely outcome happens in a game
that understanding is definitely helpful
in designing rules you wanna know what
will happen before you implement them I
wrote change melanism design is directly
aiming at designing mechanisms visit the
goal of you know making social welfare
high or making in a quality less bad or
you know many other great goals that
hopefully our companies and governments
aim to implement and I sincerely hope
that a lot of the research that's
happening here we are both have
companies design better mechanisms in
their own space and also advise the
government's in some way that's the
ultimate goal I wanted to spend at least
first sentence championing your selfless
community service and like writing books
and like selfless education your
involvement with the ACM and outreach
efforts I wanted to give you a chance to
like celebrate and amplify the work that
you're doing in all these other areas
that make the community a worthwhile
place to be a part of thank you very
much
I you know writing books I guess there
are two books associated with me the
algorithms textbook with John Kleinberg
and the this algorithmic aim Siri edited
volume for both of them I got involved
and I did it because I had a view of
what I wanted to tell the community and
the book is an excellent way to have an
impact
algorithms is a course that is taught
that virtually every school and it's
required in many many schools and we
have we had a way of wanting to teach
the course differently than many of the
textbook
I guess one important aspect is to
emphasize throughout the course how
important this applications are rather
than starting every lecture is you know
X 1 and X n R and numbers and you want
to do this every chapter every lecture
starts with some application that
explains what on earth does access might
be and we are assigning homework this
way to instead of the homework starting
with given n numbers find the median
it's some sort of English story company
once this and that if you understood the
story at the heart of it you actually
run the median but the first job for
another radioed is to understand what
the English said what did this company
really want I think this is very
important maybe one of the most
important things we're teaching is part
of algorithms and we want it to change
the course and they change the way
algorithms is taught in many many
schools to emphasize this I guess often
called the modeling aspect and so we
wrote the textbook that does this I also
really liked and again that's another
thing we do was in lectures and in the
book is not start with the correct
algorithm but start with the first
natural ID and have in lecture or in the
textbook explain of how you know this
would be a natural thing to do but it
doesn't quite work out so you have to do
this a little bit more sophisticated
thing that is to read people have some
ones sort of this algorithm rather than
just he was a beautiful algorithm done
and again there was a way I like
thinking and I wanted to sync and I you
know wanted to teach this way at Cornell
I love the idea that many other places
that adopted either the book or even
when they didn't end up the book they
adopted this way of thinking Oh
algorithmic game theory is a bit similar
it was a new field we wanted to get many
people involved so we wanted to get the
knowledge out there and I don't know I
you know I think having impact through
this getting knowledge of getting away
of thinking out there is part of what
happens in teaching - I did say I like
teaching I like bringing people who
don't yet know anything and bringing
them algorithms or bringing them game
theory or any field I know and I booked
it a little bit the same thing so it's
it serves the same way of having impact
I know you remain an inspiration for me
like my introduction to computer science
was through algorithm design Kleinberg
that was my first brush with serious
computer science research was a machine
learning project which crucially needed
a very fast network flow algorithm as a
subroutine your network my first
textbook in graduate school was
algorithm gain theory and I think
throughout grad school I was so
fortunate to have you as my you have
been an inspiration throughout and you
remain you will remain and I'm sincerely
thankful also because you know more
empirical machine learning students not
on your own publishing in naturally in a
fox talk community and yet you seem very
interested and in theoretical ideas and
we're willing to think what impact they
have in in the eye and I think people in
order for these two fields to to
successfully interact with each other we
need both sides we need people with
theoretical interest and who identifies
irritations to be interested in having
an effect but we need people from the
more empirical community to actually
be interested in reaching out and using
these ideas and it's great to have
people like you
thanks so much ever again and in fact
from all of MSL for visiting us again
and we are looking forward to many more
such visits thank you it's a great place
to visit